[Música]
la palabra de aprender se deriva del
latín
aprender está muy relacionada con la
acción de perseguir y alcanzar algo
esto denota un principio inicial en
educación
nuestros centros escolares parecieran
hoy más mini centros penitenciarios que
centros escolares donde debemos
despertar a los niños y a los jóvenes
de hecho la palabra educar se deriva del
latín educere que increíblemente
significa sacar de adentro que increíble
es esto pareciera que el maestro está en
el aula para depositar conocimiento en
el alumno y no es así el maestro está en
el aula con el alumno para sacar lo
mejor que hay dentro del alumno los
dones los virtudes los carismas y todo
eso que envuelve dentro del alma del
alumno por lo tanto los centros
escolares son un centro de laboratorio
de lo que sucede en la sociedad
lo que vemos en nuestras aulas es lo que
estamos viendo de los hogares a esos
lugares es por ello que cada docente
tiene la responsabilidad de hacer mejor
ese sentimiento del alumno en su centro
escolar y en su aula nos están llegando
niños y niñas jovencitos y jovencitas
que vienen de un infierno en su hogar y
si a eso le agregamos que llega al
centro escolar y al aula
y en vez de tener un maestro tiene un
cacique tiene un monarca que lo que
quiere es tenerlo sujeto bajo su
dirección bajo su control no vamos a
obtener resultados que estamos buscando
la clave para infundir en el alma del
alumno y en el corazón del alumno reside
en el factor del maestro efectivamente
y la primera de las ideas que yo les
ofrezco es como principio la libertad
la libertad de expresión la libertad de
sentimiento la libertad para poder hacer
lo que quiera hacer del corazón el
alumno
esta palabra la libertad tiene inherente
otra palabra que es fundamental
responsabilidad no existe libertad si no
tiene inherente la responsabilidad y de
aquí partimos para algo fundamental con
los alumnos el alumno tiene la libertad
de criticar al maestro tiene la libertad
de contradecir al maestro tiene la
libertad de pararse de jugar de reír de
cantar de llorar de expresar lo que
siente
el maestro por tanto tiene que entender
que está ahí para guiar para asesorar
para brindar ayuda no para condenar y
juzgar
cada alumno que llega a un centro
escolar tiene la gran oportunidad de
mostrar la habilidad que tiene y es mi
responsabilidad que la desarrolle y vaya
todavía más allá por tanto la primera es
libertad si queremos que un alumno
aprenda más y mejor lo primero que el
maestro debe darle a un alumno es
libertad
la segunda que es fundamental para que
un alumno aprenda más y mejor es ser
como el ser uno como ellos si tú quieres
que el alumno cante canta si tú quieres
que el alumno ría ríe si tú quieres que
el alumno llore llora junto con él
no hay nada más extraordinario para un
alumno que ver a un maestro jugar con él
al fútbol al béisbol al fútbol americano
a lo que quiera jugar es increíble que
cuando te dan tu nombramiento de maestro
pareciera que nos dan la capa del
monarca
pareciera que nos entregan una silla
presidencial nos sentamos ahí y entonces
el alumno se convierte en un sirviente
mío no no nos equivoquemos en eso soy
maestro vengo a servir te vengo a
ayudarte
vengo a liberarte
entonces ser uno como ellos es ayudarle
a pensar es ayudarle a discernir pero tú
junto con ellos hay un principio
fundamental del maestro cuando el
maestro ha dejado de aprender el maestro
por lógica ha dejado de enseñar de hecho
la gran virtud de un maestro es que no
enseña tanto como aprende de cada uno de
sus alumnos cada uno de ellos durante el
transcurso de la vida el maestro deja
algo en el corazón de uno que le ayuda a
ser un mejor ser humano si tú eres
maestro que no olvides que aprender debe
ser una causa fundamental para poder
enseñar por tanto si quieres ser como
ellos tú tienes que jugar con ellos
tienes que reír con ellos hay una parte
en el cerebro que se llama
el núcleo acumbens
y el núcleo acumbes es una parte muy
importante en el cerebro humano porque
en ella se conciben los placeres se
concibe la risa se conciben los
sentimientos de hecho está probado
científicamente que aquellas personas
que viven en soledad tienden más a
bañarse más seguido con agua caliente
tienden a tomar cosas más calientes como
el té o como el café está demostrado
también que se sientan en sillas más
rígidas y esto es porque no tiene una
compañía que le brinde ese calor
el núcleo accumbens es clave en el
cerebro humano y el alumno debe tener
igual que tú ese sentimiento de
compartir de confianza plena y total
contigo si tú te comportas como un ser
humano uno como ellos entonces él tendrá
la confianza para poder dialogar contigo
tendrán la confianza para que lo que tú
le brindes lo reciba incondicionalmente
algo fundamental en la vida entre el
alumno y el maestro es la confianza y
cómo habría de tener confianza si no te
ve como uno de ellos por tanto el
primero es libertad y el segundo es
hasta uno como ellos el tercero de estos
principios es
muestra los beneficios de haber
aprendido
muestra los beneficios al alumno para
qué sirve lo que aprendió si él no
constata en beneficios en sentimientos
de nada sirvió lo que aprendió y no solo
demuestre los beneficios que lleva al
alumno lleva al alumno a otros entornos
alternos para que pueda probar que su
que el aprendió le va a servir y le va a
generar felicidad le va a generar
bienestar le va a generar una vida mejor
todo esto que un alumno adquiere un aula
lo va a tener que reflejar en la
sociedad lo más increíble de la
educación y tal vez lo más decepcionante
nuestros días es que estamos preocupados
por exámenes internacionales estamos
preocupados que por la calidad estamos
preocupados por capacitar al maestro
pero no estamos preocupados por el
alumno y al final de cuentas quien
importa en un centro escolar es el
alumno si tú como docente te dieras
cuenta lo que tú trasciende es en el
alma y en el corazón del alumno
entenderías la trascendencia de tu
profesión es tan valiosa como aquella
que puede darle la opción de seguir
viviendo y causar malestar o bienestar a
otros seres humanos así de trascendente
es la vida de un docente y así de
trascendente es lo que podemos hacer con
esos alumnos enseñar a un alumno más y
mejor depende de estas tres libertad
hacerte uno como ellos y mostrar los
beneficios del aprendizaje es imposible
que un alumno se atreva a querer seguir
aprendiendo si el no beneficios él no ve
los beneficios de aprender
es normal en un aula cuando un alumno le
estás explicando y no lo entiende y
levanta la mano
profe yo no lo entiendo voy para allá
josé y cuando va uno con jose mira no sé
la cuestión está así volteas a ver su
cara y desencajado tú sin que te diga
nada tú sabes que no te entiende ni papá
y tú le preguntas ya me entendiste jose
hijo se te hace cara una desilusión
tremenda y te dice sí
tú sabes que no es cierto jose vamos a
mi escritorio vamos a explicarte ahí se
levanta a jose y vamos a explicarle mira
jose vamos a explicárselo de otra manera
porque esa manera no funcionó de mi
parte de mi parte en mi responsabilidad
y cuando estás explicando de repente
aparece en su cara unos ojos brillosos y
una sonrisa hasta las orejas
voltea itv y aparece como una como un
sonido de telenovela de televisa y te
dice profe
ya no entendí
y tú valoras ese momento como el mejor
de tu historia como maestro tu lo voltea
si lo ves y también quisieras abrazarlo
como en una novela de televisa y decirle
jose
qué extraordinario momento claro que no
lo haces guardas compostura y le dices
ya jose jose si profe y se va muy feliz
a su lugar y empiezan las manos y el
cuerpo a demostrar que efectivamente ha
comprendido el asunto
cuantos de estos momentos se repiten en
tu aula cuántos momentos de felicidad se
repiten con tus alumnos cuántos momentos
de gratitud cuántos momentos de
trascendencia le estás dejando ese niño
o esa niña cuántos momentos de felicidad
le estás infundiendo para que cuando
llegue a su hogar al infierno donde vive
pueda resistir eso que está viviendo
allá el centro escolar y el aula es la
única salvación que le queda de hecho
hay alumnos y alumnas que te lo dicen
profe yo quisiera que no terminara la
escuela yo quisiera que no hubiera
vacaciones yo quisiera que el horario
fuera ahora de siete de la mañana a
siete de la noche yo le digo no mi hija
no se exagera yo también tengo familia
pero es porque quiere más estar contigo
en el aula y en el centro escolar que en
su propio hogar hoy tenemos que luchar y
vencer esas barreras estamos más
preocupados de qué pensarán los demás de
mí que lo que debo de hacer por los
demás cuando me hice maestro entendía
algo por convicción
así de trascendente en la vida es ser
maestro
y espero que lo entendamos y lo
comprendamos de esta manera es tan
trascendente ser maestro que salvas
vidas así de grande es esta profesión
salvas vidas iluminas vidas trasciendes
en el alma de sus pequeños seres humanos
después ellos se llenan de esperanza y
se llenan de ánimo para continuar en la
vida y después de las tropas más grandes
y cuando te ven aunque tú ya no te
acuerdas a veces que me ven y me dicen
profe y tengo que voltear a ver a mi
esposa decirle dime quién es y me dice
ella si tú no lo conoces yo - fue tu
alumno bueno pero lo viste en una foto
algo de graduación no no lo conozco
finge que lo conoces cómo está mi
estimado alumno que dice mi profe cómo
va ese pelo pues ya ves cada vez menos
mi profe como lo quiero
como lo extraño maestro te casaste si le
digo esa es la razón que me extraña no
me extrañe ya te metiste en los estrenos
ya tenía algo de ayuda para que lo
enfrente
pero te lo dicen con una gratitud porque
saben que ellos vivían una historia de
terror y en la escuela encontraron una
historia de felicidad y a pesar de que
va a haber una separación tarde o
temprano de sus alumnos él deja marcado
su corazón por lo que vio en ese centro
escolar y en esa aula incluso hay
alumnos y alumnas que me dicen maestro
no se me olvida aquella frase a mí ya se
me olvidó
cual mica
qué es más valioso profesor es más
valioso el conocimiento en práctica que
la teoría muerta hay veces que me quedo
sorprendido y yo dije eso
entonces obviamente finjo y hago una
cara de especialista en la materia claro
mi hija esa frase se la digo a todos
cada alumno se lleva de ti una parte
no ha habido momentos en que tope un
alumno un alumno y derrame lágrimas por
ellos también de orgullo pero más que
eso de felicidad cada ser humano en este
país está lleno de virtudes y de dones a
este país no le hacen falta nuevos
gobernantes a este país lo que le hace
falta es que cada uno de nosotros
saquemos de adentro de esos seres
humanos todas las virtudes y dones que
tienen este país está lleno de talento
lo peor que nos puede pasar en educación
no es que reprueben exámenes escritos
quítense esa idea los exámenes escritos
no los vas a enfrentar en la vida cuando
se te ponche una llanta no vas a sacar
el manual no no lo peor que le puede
pasar a un país en la educación es que
se nos esté yendo al drenaje la cantidad
enorme de jóvenes con tantos talentos y
virtudes jóvenes especialistas para
tocar instrumentos musicales jóvenes
especialistas para la poesía jóvenes
especialistas para las matemáticas
jóvenes especialistas para las ciencias
y qué está pasando con ellos qué
historia están escribiendo más allá de
donde yo lo dejé no lo sabemos
por eso recordándote estos tres
principios libertad
hazte uno como ellos enseñan los
beneficios del aprendizaje y grabaste
esto en el corazón hay una combinación
hermosa que no se debe pasar en esta
vida
que esta vida es muy hermosa y de que tú
naciste para ser feliz y si nos damos
cuenta de eso vamos a lograr grandes
cosas fue un placer haber compartido con
ustedes hoy el maestro repa y espero
volvernos a ver próximamente chao
[Aplausos]